it's seeker of not play yard bird again
here we are Eric LeBron is going evil
that's not happening often normally
plays um d 4 against me probably being
satisfied with the stuff that he gets
okay let's play my word line here k is
playing an on theoretical continuation
with 23 that's an option that white
always has for just getting a game let's
say
yeah this is a setup that I like against
this this some kind of structure with d3
night nights over there on the queenside
and my bishops are keeping the Knights
here from g5 and so on yep of course wyd
can open up the center I don't think
it's particularly dangerous but it's
played quite often yeah if he takes now
I have Bishop f6 for some activity let's
I think a nice position 23 have to think
about them made on age 7 if he goes
Bishop fyf Knight to c4 as this is I
already have played a number of times
already and I think I'm really okay can
also take be too that's that's also
possible here black is actually a little
bit better developed so yeah this is
this is too tempting I will take will
take that okay um okay taking this rook
okay we should pay to isn't coming but
not sure how dangerous that is I have g5
i also have rook a seven to defend he's
not touristy tricky though i have to
always be alert probably with saying
that I'm blundering stuff that's how it
happens okay my night on b6 is
unprotected this is something that I
have to have to be aware of naija form
maybe so this is not happening that the
bishop is going to just kill me 94 may
be coming yeah let's let's just activate
you Queen Here I am I have an active
position yet it's not that I have to
defend passively
if i get if five then things get much
much clearer and simpler ob2 i would
like to take me to him and if I've still
hangs come on let's take it getting e55
graders I adds that it's really a bit
much now I'm okay yeah this this kind of
went blew up in his face I actually
believe that d 4 is not a good move in
this position it happens quite often
that they play it but it it opens up the
position at a moment where black is kind
of ready for it maybe be to Bishop b2 I
mean white it's not substantially worse
it's just that here after that I think
I'm really comfortable I'm a little bit
better develop and this Bishop is strong
I had I had this a number of times and I
think like is this really okay and this
is simply blundering the pawn Joe and
here the exchange champ that was kind of
a disaster yeah I was thinking you
should maybe keep the bishop somehow to
make things more complicated but all i
have i have those moves also yeah it was
a pretty pretty straightforward victory
kind of anti climatic usually have those
big battles but sometimes he also just
blunder stuff here on a two so that was
a was a nice game and I'm glad to have a
winning against him but it wasn't wasn't
a big fight as usual okay well thanks
for watching